[Music]
have you guys found yourselves getting
more easily distracted during these
these times I'm always easily this what
I mean distract distract from water yeah
distracted from what won't work all like
not being productive it's like you're
constantly just getting distracted like
it's like all of a sudden now you have
I'm more relaxed the way that the world
is right now it's causing a lot of
people to suffer from anxiety I feel
like we're on vacation all the time
right now like for the past month we've
been on a vacation and so yes I have
been more a DD like a staycation huh
yeah I guess staycation so I'm like hi
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter if I
work today or not because right back to
doing the same thing every day I think
I'm really hyper focused actually yeah I
feel like I'm working more than I did
before
I don't think anything has changed yeah
we were talking about this the other day
and I think it's because our lives and
the way that we work is already similar
to quarantine style life like no one's
ever had to tell me when to work how to
work bla bla like that's always been up
to me so now that this quarantine has
has happened it's the same for me yeah I
dream if I don't work I don't make money
coming into film together there's no
real schedule we have to figure when we
do the meetings you know all that other
stuff yeah I agree with you guys but
apparently a lot of people who like
usually have their nine-to-five now all
of a sudden they're having to have that
drastic shift from working in an office
to working at home and a lot of people
or just have like heightened anxiety
because of it so there's like three tips
here to help get you like less
distracted or more work so like for
example is have a designated area in
your house to work and like yeah like
just have that one corner in your place
and that's dedicated for work don't work
on your bed and clean it clean that area
too is it makes you feel better when
you're sitting there exactly
yeah and then also they have this so the
second thing is to give yourself time to
have a break you allow yourself to have
that time of distraction or or to have
that time of like meditation or
mindfulness for you to like get centered
so there's this technique where you're
twenty five minutes on and then five
minutes off and so that's like how you
can maybe get more productive where
you're actually designated designating
yourself a break like time for a break
and not just constantly because a lot of
people what they end up doing now since
they're not used to it working from home
is they'll you know like they'll slowly
jump into the work day like pretty much
like I didn't snail speed it's just like
okay fine I guess I'll do something here
a little bit of this and then like
something will pop up a notification in
your phone and then you spend hours on
that and then you kind of like triple
back into work and then you end up
working really really late into the
night because you're like well I don't
have anything else to do and then it
just really [ __ ] with your mind and you
end up getting larger amounts of stress
because of it I'm bumping up against
that a little bit only cuz I've read
some studies and just my own personal
experience where stop start working
actually takes longer for people because
they it takes them longer to get back
into work flow mode yeah once they stop
once it took a little break exactly so
those for me so for me yeah you got to
be in Saigon a binge work I have to I
have to like so you know we'll be on the
script for like eight hours nine hours
ten hours because that is how I get the
most productive and then when I stop I
can really stop and actually reward
myself for working yeah maybe this is
kind of like a if it works for you
typically yeah cuz for me personally I
feel like I definitely need my breaks
like I can like get zoned in for like an
hour or two and then I'm like oh [ __ ]
I'm like depleted of energy like I need
to [ __ ] take a break and you have
lunch or some [ __ ] like move away from
this and then like refresh myself and
then depending on what I'm doing if I'm
doing worked I just don't like then I
need a break like even like every like
15 minutes I'll be like I just I just
can't step away from this right now just
to like step away from the dread I guess
ya know watching a movie with a
girlfriend exactly oh my god
for me at my 80 be so strong that like I
can get lost in anything and spend a
stupid amount of time and everything so
like usually before I start my workday
or whatever I'll write all the tasks
down that I'm gonna do like the list and
also the time so like let's say council
fly on through whatever right I know I
should never I shouldn't be over on the
phone for over 10 minutes or 15 minutes
like every single item or errand that I
have to do I don't calculate that you've
done it's like I'm the you you've done
so many things amount of time like if
someone calls hey can you get this from
a library you could kind of like
guesstimate like just a rough amount of
time how do you gain that data because
in the past when you have done that task
you have timed yourself you're like oh
this is how long it takes me know just
coming just like a mental gauge like if
I don't give myself a time limit I could
be in the grocery store for six hours
and I'm just getting there I know what
that's like right so instead of being
lost into whatever I'm doing I have to
like fight like if I do need to get
[ __ ] portobello mushrooms on rlq in
like ten minutes
so I know this is how much how much time
we're all so I can get lost doing
anything so you are the way you are
because you can be horrible at it I get
it
yeah yeah yeah cuz I could just dive
into like the rabbit hole I never come
out and then I come out and I'm like oh
[ __ ] only did one of the things I wanted
to do today and then that being was the
stupidest thing it wasn't even like a
priority yeah I've never been able to
guess them at a time I would be on the
phone with customer service ever like
hours later yeah come on if I wrote down
like let's say my experience was like
five or ten minutes as soon as it gets
to ten minutes I just hang up I don't
try to pursue it until I reach a
resolved then I go okay what's my second
Avenue I'll email them I'll email them
and then maybe at the end them on
Twitter or someplace shouldn't we call
customer services should we call
customer [ __ ] yes be honest about
what I'm getting yeah I have that bad
gamblers mentality where I'm like I have
committed this much time to it I've been
on the phone for 30 minutes what's
another 10 minutes and then two hours in
and you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] up
investment it's called something like
investment something like you've
invested already so much engine no I'm
sorry [ __ ] I get pissed
cuz I'll think about it for days until
it's done but also I started to keep a
note of all the things of what to do
like I gotta get my real ID or whatever
it's sometime
things will pop in my head when I'm like
washing the dishes or something and I'm
like oh you have to do that one thing
I'll do it later if I don't write that
[ __ ] down I'm gonna think about it in a
week later and go oh I have to clip my
nails
well like I have to do this other oh my
god yeah so if I say that in my head I'm
like [ __ ] I run to my laptop and I write
it in my list and then every week I look
at the most important things to do and
in the tasks and all that and it's a
[ __ ] mountain of [ __ ] I heavily use
my reminders app on the iPhone is that
so much I love it I love alerts and
alarms and [ __ ] on my phone it's the
[ __ ] well for me works the opposite if I
have an alarm I don't know why but my
brain is wired this way I need to ignore
it I can't believe you're a successful
mother all this [ __ ] to ignore it
patient zero of like having the worst
kid and the words out and everything and
somehow you may not work it's it's weird
though she's like anything to do with
Isaac she's like amazing in it and then
anything that has to do with her herself
it's like yeah it's like my mom this is
this is the way I haven't been able to
survive in this world is because
whenever someone else is on the line
like if I'm if I'm gonna be
disappointing someone else I can't have
that so I have to do the thing you could
disappoint yourself for some reason I'll
be like oh it's not that there's your
supporter you should just put Isaac in
the beans that you've been whining like
Sinai is up Isaac up for yoga classes
that Lonnie class is getting his hair
dyed and in that way you live through
him I want to say this in earnest you
don't deserve disappointment seriously
that's very sweet
no because really cuz that's what we do
to ourselves I've done that to myself -
a lot what does that mean you don't
deserve so we do that to ourselves where
it's like the person who should be
punished as me I would take care of
everyone around me I won't take care of
myself as much but you don't deserve
disappointment and I don't either and
that happened to me for a couple years
where I was doing that to myself so I'll
give you a little bit of me how dare you
disappoint me you son of a [ __ ] but
yeah I don't know
like during this whole quarantine thing
though I did like shifted a bit because
well I actually know if people lie down
not really but yes you did yes you did
but because of the like I've been
focusing and putting like all my energy
into creating a nice home for us to live
in and I was gonna say that that was
selfish but not really because they live
there too yeah but that's great you and
yes that's something for you too yeah
cuz you take joy in that like I remember
when you helped me design my room and
all that that was really fun even those
for me but it was like a project that
you enjoyed so it is for you ultimately
to what a few tape like five pound
dumbbells to all the paintbrushes so
that way when you're paying in the house
should also give your work out here
that's something Bart would come up with
a jean that is pretty genius it's let's
try to find a way to work out and then
your paint is all [ __ ] up like I'm
mostly painted at the bottom half of
this thing it's good it's heavy you a
[ __ ] rat ran beef right in front of
my face when I was working out in the
garage other smell no I was doing like a
[ __ ] shoulder press and I look over
and his little [ __ ] Mouse runs from
in outside of my driveway inside right
in front of me crosses me and I'm like
why the [ __ ] are you coming in here did
you get you to get it out no well I
chased his ass and you went behind my
boxes and I'm like [ __ ] I can't get him
now do you ever you have a mouse there's
a little mouse in my garage my dog keeps
bringing in dead rats right now I don't
know why he just started doing this all
he said yeah like the worst thing would
be to have like a momma rat come in and
then like give birth yeah to like a
whole bunch a little rat I love that
we're all talking about our feelings and
then and this and this open with don't
get distracted and then Joe's like I saw
a mouse
I will stain
okay boards double reference maybe think
of backing out all right I know you got
people this show is so underrated
[Laughter]
it was linear thinking in my plan nobody
wrote an issue down beforehand it was
perfect I love it there is a meaning to
my chaos though when people go hey man
that's out of the blue and I'm like is
it is yeah it was you have to meet you
have to connect the dots for us what
there you go he did he did dumbbells we
got working out his very mouse in front
of me while I was working out I wouldn't
change it for the world
[Music]